Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Dider and I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor
with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series, we're going to be taking a quick look at how to
use the water tools inside of Unreal Engine 5.
This is first going to start with us enabling the water tools plugin and restarting the
editor.
We're then going to take a look at how a world needs to be set up so that the water
tools can be utilized inside of that world.
We'll then take a look at each of the tools by exploring the ocean, lake and river tools
individually.
We'll then take a look at how we can bind all of the tools together in one single map
and then we'll finish up by talking about waves and buoyancy.
We've got a lot to cover, so let's go ahead and get started with enabling the plugin.